bonsoir claire milo merci d'être avec
nous ce soir sur arte france alors on le
disait au moins 31 morts aujourd'hui
dans la manche tout d'abord votre votre
sentiment votre réaction après cette
nouvelle
là ma réaction est double d'abord c'est
une grande grande tristesse parce que on
se doutait que ça allait arriver ça
devait forcément arriver un jugement
mais c'est une chose de le savoir
abstraitement c'est une autre d'avoir la
nouvelle au téléphone voilà plus de
trente dont on est en train de retirer
les corps de l'eau et alors là d'un seul
coup c'est autre chose et en boucle et
en même temps qu'on y répondre et on est
en colère en colère parce que justement
ce avec ça et ça arrive à cause des
conditions dans lesquelles ces gens ce
lui main d'abord la survie à cannes et
un oui il ya une image la côte et un
jour sur deux démantèlement de tout le
matériel impossibilité de garder des
affaires de stocker autre chose que ce
qu'on portait dans ses bras et sur son
dos un possibilité de stocker des
vêtements de rechange les couvertures un
peu nombreuses des provisions et cetera
et puis un possibilité de demander
l'asile à le gouvernement nous dit le
préfet dit on les mâles à brisbane et
les emmène dans des centres où ils sont
censés pouvoir demander l'accueil mais
quelqu'un qui est dégoûté c'est à dire
qui a été refusée à qui on a refusé le
droit d'asile que ce soit en france ou
en allemagne dans un pays scandinave
cette personne là elle est coincée un
peu pâle à redon nouveau demandé l'asile
une personne qui a ses empreintes dublin
dans un autre pays d'europe que la
france c'est à dire le règlement dublin
dit que les gens doivent demander
l'asile dans le premier pays dans lequel
on a pris leurs empreintes digitales
mais ces gens-là ne peuvent pas demander
l'asile en france s'ils demandent
l'asile c'est comme quand ils sont
déboutés ils se retrouvent ensemble de
rétention avec le renvoi soit dans le
pays où ils ont les empreintes soient
dans leur pays d'origine donc c'est de
l'hypocrisie se dire qu'on les met à
l'abri et avec cette absence de solution
bourreau des mais se disent ya plus qu
en angleterre elle peut comme angleterre
qu'on peut arriver à trouver tout un
train moyens de travailler au noir nous
gagner sa vie pas largement mais de
gagner sa vie et de mener une vie
normale
lee 80 avec un logement avec
avec un travail bien vous vous disiez
l'instant que vous n'aviez pas été
surprise que vous vous y attendiez est
ce que le démantèlement du camp de
grande synthe le 16 novembre dernier à
peut-être un peu précipité les choses
les savoirs je suis pas sûr ça fait
tellement longtemps qu'on démantèle sur
les deux sites que je suis pas sûr que
le dernier est vraiment été graves que
d'autres la décision qui a été prise par
contre monsieur darmana que des passeurs
il a raison comptez pas sur moi pour
défendre les passeurs sont des criminels
mais il faudrait quand même pas oublier
que si à des passeurs c'est parce
qu'elle chantait interdite un an 40
entre la france occupée la france libre
c'était des passeurs aider les gens à
franchir cette ligne on les appelle pas
comme ça parce que ça donne maintenant
une image négative mais c'étaient des
passeurs et se faisait payer vont pas
les mêmes prix maintenant mais c'était
la même réalité une frontière interdite
fait que ya forcément des passeurs qui
se met à gagner là j'ai pensé alors vous
parlez de gérald darmanin le ministre de
l'intérieur était un tout à l'heure dans
la région
selon vous il a il a utilisé bien sûr
les passeurs selon vous est ce que la
france a aussi une responsabilité dans
ce drame bien sûr comme je vous disais
tout à l'heure les gens ne peuvent pas
demander l'asile parce qu'ils se soient
dégoûtés soit avec ses empreintes du bla
et une façon de résoudre des problèmes
c'est de lever ses empreintes dublin ce
que l'état français a parfaitement le
droit de faire ce qui s'est passé il ya
cinq ans on est en train de commémorer
entre guillemets on le fait pas et en
profiter on est en train d'évoquer
beaucoup les 50 évacuation de la grande
jungle quand bernard cazeneuve a fait
évacuer la cantine 4000 personnes sont
parties dont il a levé les empreintes du
blanc ces quatre mille ans les a pas vus
ils se sont installés en concile ont été
acceptés sont trouvé un travail il ya
deux pour mille demandeurs d'asile en
france c'est rien du tout liban siens
sur trois ou peut accueillir ou peut
accueillir les gens en france et ne
retrouver du travail il ya du travail en
france y ait des restaurateurs pas de
travail gens vont travailler il ya des
écoles qui ferment parce qu'à pas
d'enfant ou qu' on peut accueillir c'est
juste une volonté politique et une
réunion interministérielle a lieu demain
au tour de jean castex justement sur sur
le sujet qu'est ce que vous attendez de
ce genre de réunion pas grand chose pas
grand chose parce que je pense que d'ici
10 ou 20 mai que d'ici les élections
présidentielles y aura pas une décision
d'importance d'envergure qui permettent
un accueil et je le regrette énormément
je pense que les partis de gauche
devraient avoir le courage de dire voilà
maintenant ce qu'il faut faire au lieu
de décider de grignoter les bois de 2 0
en faisant une politique en proposant
une politique d'extrême mois
merci beaucoup que l'hermine au d'avoir
était avec nous ce soir sur arte france
rappelle que vous êtes secrétaire
général de l'association salam qui vient
en aide aux migrants à calais et à
grande synthe merci beaucoup